et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec calais maupin
correspondant verte et aux états unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
bonsoir calais maupin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donald
trump qui a donc reconnu un qu'il était
au courant de la gravité du coronavirus
dès le début du mois de février et qu'il
avait volontairement minimiser le danger
c'est une révélation de taille comment
est elle accueillie aux états unis hier
qu'il essayait d'éviter une bad luck
qu'il a essayé de changer le discours
pour se concentrer sur le fait que pop
ou porta attendu avant de révéler ces
informations
de la trempe essaye donc de détourner la
conversation et il dit qu'il s'agissait
d'une tentative d'influencer le reste à
des élections mais pour beaucoup
d'américains
ça ne change rien et effectivement la
gestion de crise donald trump semble
être au centre des préoccupations
électorales des américain donald trump
est en retard dans beaucoup de sondages
et beaucoup d'américains ont l'intention
de voter pour jobs hayden plutôt que
donald trump
cependant ce n'est pas le vote populaire
qui détermine le président des états
unis les grands électeurs et il y aura
certes un état clé pour déterminer le
président et certains de ces états clés
sont encore des bastions du président
des états comme loyaux le michigan le
risque si nous la pennsylvanie
malgré l'opposition grandissante et sa
chute dans les sondages de popularité
la situation reste encore en suspens
alors vous dites effectivement vouliez
cette affaire à la présidentielle vous
avez bien raison parce que l'affairé
grave tout de même de notre homme
continuera de dire publiquement un que
le virus n'est pas pire que la grippe
que la situation est sous contrôle ou
encore que le nombre de cas sera bientôt
de 2,0 clairement est ce qu'on peut se
poser la question est ce qu'il va me les
américains
danger avec son attitude un excellent
j'en suis certain c'était inacceptable
dans une telle période dans une telle
crise
il est intolérable de recevoir des
messages aussi discordants de la part
des différents médias et des différentes
autorités
je trouve le comportement de donna
transmet également d'autres figurent
d'autres personnalités qui nous essayer
à qui étaient censés informer le pognon
je trouve leur comportement intolérable
leurs actions et leurs paroles ne
correspondait pas à ce qui était
nécessaire
nous aurions dû bénéficier de toutes les
informations nécessaires et la gestion
de crise aurait pu être bien meilleur si
le système américain le système de santé
avaient tous bénéficié des mêmes
informations
donald trump se défend en disant qu'il
essayait d'éviter la panique qui ne
voulait pas faire souffrir les marchés
boursiers donald trump était inquiet il
pensait que s'il ne misait pas la
situation alors cela a reçu un impact
sur la bourse américaine
et pourtant l'économie a déjà beaucoup
souffert donc je pense que beaucoup
d'américains n'accepteront pas cet
argument et pourtant il a encore
beaucoup de soutien il ya beaucoup de
personnes dans des états clés qui
considère que donald trump et leurs
défenseurs face à ce qu'ils considèrent
comme l'establishment américain
donc on ne sait pas vraiment si cela va
influencer le résultat des élections
mais donald trump a déjà prouvé qu'il
était un président problématique que ces
actions n'étaient pas dignes
en tout cas il continua sa communication
par rapport à cette crise sanitaire
on le sent
en fonction de la présidentielle puisque
la désormais il promet aux américains
avec ça avant le 3 novembre
[Musique]
il a également retiré les états unis des
efforts pour développer un vaccin au
niveau international et il ya des
tensions très fortes entre les états
unis et le ms mac pompéo continue à dire
que c'est la chine qui est responsable
de cette pandémie et qu'elle devrait
payer cdu la stratégie de
l'administration est assez brouillonne
s'il voulait développer un vaccin
rapidement alors on pourrait penser
qu'il souhaiterait coopérer avec non
seulement la chine également l'aise tous
les pays du monde
cependant une idéologie nationaliste et
isolationnistes de l'administration trup
conditionnent leurs actions donc
effectivement les décisions sont très
une fuse et il ya beaucoup de programmes
différents au sein de la maison blanche
coq ou de courants politiques différents
beaucoup de courants politiques
différents sur lequel donald trump a
construit sa coalition
merci caleb maupin d'avoir été avec nous
correspondons d'ayrté aux états unis
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir